dab in white I have no idea how to start
a business I'm scared to try I fear that
investors will either not take me
seriously or I will have been taking
advantage of somehow I have faith in my
idea but not my ability to make it a
reality I just got a number one take
that word behind Evan believe right so
kind of let's not get the sequence wrong
as well forget the investors focus on
the idea if the idea and then focus on
who the target customers are if you've
got those right investors will flopped
you you don't have to worry about those
guys you'll have money chasing you
everywhere but you don't want that
because that's just the wrong ethos for
building a business you want to start
with the idea then go and find the
customers refine the idea to have a
winning product or a service and then
you can always find money for great
businesses and growth businesses that's
the least your problems I'm probably
actually have on one of these we should
do how do you find kind of growth money
and growth capital and all those sort of
things because there's a whole topic in
itself but the last thing to do is go to
the investors focus focus focus on the
idea and get the business going do it
now JD I yeah that was the theme of the
show I like it I mean I couette totally
agree you'll get destroyed on your
valuation if you take money before you
have any kind of momentum behind it and
you spend your whole time trying to
raise money instead of actually trying
to build a company um the thing I would
say to add is when you start anything
you're afraid right like you want to
learn snowboarding you're afraid of
going down that hill or get enough for
me was getting off the chairlift was
freaking me out because you only have
one foot on the support i was falling
down every time but anything anything
that you try for the first time you're
going to be afraid to do and then once
you start doing it it's not that bad it
doesn't seem as bad as this huge fear
that you set up in your head and so it
may help us to look at all the other
things that you try to do whether it was
you know asking that girl out or
learning that new language you're going
to that new country whatever it is uh
you had
fear and you overcame it and once you
did it you realize it wasn't that hard
it's the same thing with business just
start there's no right first step are
you going to make mistakes you don't
need to get the investors yet the link
it's this huge big thing just take one
step after another after another after
another and those little steps will add
up to big steps hey vlv Evan obviously
people can listen to you because you
inspire people but there's a couple of
armed examples both service people so we
talked about will we've got a lot of
people in here Vitas games have had
stuff like their legs blown off and
there are saying I'm gonna be successful
as an entrepreneur so if those kinds can
do it wow you can do it you should have
no fear the other guy who's had almost
three careers amazing it was in the
military guy called Justin back Shaw
amazing guy Ted speaker but then he
became an explorer and adventurer and he
climbed Everest I think he's sailed
around the world he's been to the North
Pole South Pole multiple times he's
taken disabled service people on these
expeditions and made them believe and
I'm but overcome matical physical
disabilities and he also runs he's got a
really nice jewelry business high
quality in London town so he also said
to me is you know when you're getting up
Everest it's not about getting up is
about coming down I think one in six
people died coming down on something
crazy like that and the mission for
everybody in business is almost like an
analogy that comes from exploring is
you've got to get everybody safely
landed and safely down and he said when
you've dealt with the fear of facing
death so bleakly and you know storms
coming in you should have no fear in
your business so I think I you know just
when you when you look at these people
there's so many inspirational people out
there and you just got over your [ __ ]
fear and the way you do that is always
take your first step you know we could
quote Martin Luther King how do you
climb a giant staircase you just take
the first step you just got to take the
first step next Monday just think how
you gonna do it build your product take
your idea to market go and test it go
and share with friends and family and
and then
you build confidence and then you find
out what will work you refine your idea
your course correct and you'll have a
product that's a winner in the
marketplace ego believe what really
helped me in my company because I didn't
mind you know my parents weren't
entrepreneurs I didn't have any
entrepreneur friends and have a uncle
joe who could guide me uh I just wanted
myself with stories of successful
entrepreneurs and how they got started
and every morning I would read a quick
story but a famous entrepreneur how they
got started and you know how they
usually had nothing and it provided me
with both the motivation to keep going
and it's like if they could do it than I
could do it and also some strategies for
like ideas of what I could do because
you don't really learn this stuff in
school and so that really really helped
me and so having an environment that you
create it's only easier now there's so
many YouTube videos out there's so many
books you can read something kind of
daily to get you going to motivate you
and make you believe in yourself I think
it's crucial for any entrepreneur
because it's a hard lonely game this if
you have to start when you have any
momentum building up so creating an
environment for greatness is a super
important in my opinion if there's any
kids out there you know you're twelve
thirteen fourteen listening today then I
would say there's some amazing network
setup one is junior achievers where we
sponsor those guys across the US and
across the world again what we the links
but they've got a whole environment
they've got these I'm simulated towns
where you can start up your own business
and there's loads of entrepreneurs
around to help you and also they can set
up mentoring so if you don't have a
network or a family of entrepreneurs
there's loads of different ways to
actually get that so don't feel
constrained and go out and find the
people who are going to help you and
again there's so many voices in your
head to tell you people won't be
prepared to give you their time people
love to see young kids succeed people
love to be asked to help young
entrepreneurs so go and ask people
people you respect people you can learn
from and people who have made a lot of
mistakes in their own careers of
entrepreneurship
help you kind of navigate a really
successful path